sie kommen zur heutigen video ich bin
zusammen mit luca hier
juni klettere kamera wie blöde ist
extrem warm draußen und wir sind im kopf
ist kaputt von den ganzen spaß
ich habe ein bisschen wenig was für ein
video und ich bin zum schluss gekommen
die detektoren und hübscher zu machen
wie über juden gesprochen
ja ich weiß nicht ob wir das kennt er
auch das zu eurer zeit auch die war aber
früher liefen immer im fernsehen so
werbung so die fms mit 30 33 und
erhalten sie nackt scanner für gratis
und dann war es versteckte abo kopf wie
wunderbaren apps gibt es mittlerweile im
app store und jeder kann sie sich
runterladen ich auch besser machen wir
das jetzt wir haben hier vier es
insgesamt vorbereitet muss man schon
sagen ja das ist hier ein arbeitsaufwand
das ist unvergleichlich der
lügendetektor der funktioniert indem man
seine finger ein scan lässt denn das
beauty meter das bewertet wie schön man
ist wir gucken hier noch mal ganz genau
auf das apple logo und der x-ray scanner
wahrscheinlich der grund weshalb wir
alle auf dieses video geklickt habe und
zu guter letzt sexy kappel game
warum wird immer klarer ab aber ich habe
die ganzen schweiz besuchen dann war das
auch der beiden so als allererstes leute
lügendetektor ich würde ich gern richtig
gut linien starten ich sage analyse 50
cent nur nein danke ok zeige und
mittelfinger passieren was sage ich luca
macht guten content betriebe ist es eine
lüge renault david garrett gefährlich
war bin ich erinnere aber eben im
biologischen der zeit von 7 hat einen
wieder eingebaut sänger und musiker
prince kevin gegen meine antwort
abgeschlossen
ok macht luca guten content wenn er
jetzt besteht dann hast du machst
schächten konzern schauen wir es kein
ergebnis
ja ja ja aber ich gerade gepustet hat
max
also ich sage jetzt ich habe gar den fuß
denn dort wahrheit steht das war falsch
die das ist es nicht mag haarige putzen
und das heißt ich auch gern starten im
pazifik befragen und mittelfinger
platzieren meine damen und herren die
mittelfinger und zeigefinger sind ob die
nun darauf erfährt man wie vier super
wieder funktioniert kommen das geld geld
es gehen wenn du die wahrheit dann habe
wirklich geputzt und machst du tust
ergebnis ist da sieht man halt es wieder
die etwa 100 gab auch eine letzte frage
formulieren bevor die kamera treten war
möchtest du den einzig funktionierenden
lügendetektor im ganzen universum
universum
was mich zu fragen überlegt was drin ist
das gute ist so nah kommen
wir brauchen deine frage für die
lügendetektor sollte mich abonnieren
sollte sondern diese sinnvoll ist es
sinnvoll solche leute jona abonnieren
nein nein das wäre so kraft ist generell
das geld vorgang läuft es ist einfach
unglaublich was die heutige technik
ermöglicht oder verkürzen abhebt einen
finger an
also stimmt es dass die leute immer
abonnieren sollten wahres alter text
annimmt oder moment mal
bisher hat eigentlich alles gestimmt
also macht so guten content ich würde
ich mal vier jahren aus norwegen fusion
sollten die leute abonnieren das heißt
vielleicht funktioniert er ja wirklich
wie sie sagen der flüge bekommen hat wie
dieses youtube es den sound of warcraft
richtig viel höher bei der arbeit
eigentlich falsch oder button in den
beiden finger okay okay
die wünschenswerte natürlich jetzt
einige teams überlastung also in
reagiert aber sagt lüderitz ii fun an
unseren beiden identitäten erkrankte
waren die flüge an sagt dass es wirklich
funktioniert max zubereiten okay wir
nehmen die hand runter und ihr seht
schon heute das kernergebnis möglich
macht junge aber die wahrscheinlichkeit
bei fifty fifty
das ist roy geringen alter tätigen erst
mal eine andere es aber am schluss
bleibt dran
hätten wir das noch mal als nächstes
haben wir die power of duty meter die ja
wow
guck dir das mal an luca das ist kein
richtig
ein foto von uns jetzt nicht gespannt
gewinnt
wir werden regelrecht von dem schneemann
natürlich profitiert aber 10 scheint gut
zu sein medizin so leute wir nehmen
jetzt mal ein bild von jona ist das foto
von jona jetzt benutzen wir jetzt
eigentlich mit weniger kinder wäre
korrekt war
ich dachte wirklich ich lass ich lasse
jetzt die app herunter und nichts davon
funktioniert aber konnte alles gefallen
ist hat gestimmt wir sind wieder mit
ihren auf jeden fall sicher genau wenn
jetzt noch der nacktscanner funktioniert
so weiter musste sie die leute gerne
fäuste kemmer etwa die smart camera ok
luca ja du bist jetzt derjenige der nach
es ist wunderbar man sie total wie echt
das video jetzt wieder gegeben und es
kennt das ganze geld erhalte die
kostenlosen kontakt auf und saniertes
gesehen
freescale okay nochmals der nagel den
wieder haft
jupiter hat mich ja meine kämpfe
eindeutig ja sonst im sand herum und
eine ebita inhaltlich mehr verfügt die
ag hat jene von diesem geist gerne alten
früher nie bestellt weil ich auch nicht
alles fertig so konnte die erklärung
gegeben
hier letztes spiel 6 kg im gesetz
wahrscheinlich machen geht aber nach
einem subtilen nachspielt starten lassen
geplant ist das machen aus nach wahrheit
ok lud sie muss wo wirst du am liebsten
gar nicht erwarten wieder von das waren
meine lieblings youtube ein video kann
in ihrer corvette leute irgendwie mein
letztes video war über nacht war der
übelste sportler ist einfach all dem
wird und dieses hier stimmt ein wenn ich
die beste plattform stelle ja gut dann
lache man leichter wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal
bis dahin macht es gut und genießt das
schöne wetter daten ist wie ein gutes
video war der future sogar